all right so why has no one told me that
Dragon Ball's anime filler has a beta
room of spirit and time called the room
of time no spirit in this one it's just
a a room full of clocks I guess but it's
essentially from what I can tell a room
that lets you time travel Goku travels
back in time and hangs out with a young
Master roshiin Company and wacky Antics
and sunoles but like why why is this a
thing the anime invented like they
didn't stop to think that inventing such
an insanely useful room would seem odd
if it's never brought up again like my
point here is that future Bulma wasted
all her time making the time machine at
because trunk should have just flown to
the lookout and used the room of time to
meet Goku and then train I guess